Let's revisit the semantics of LRVM and what it does. So
this is a time axis, the application when it calls the begin transaction
primitive of LRVN. What LRVN does is it says,
okay, the application is going to modify some portion of the memory.
So let me create a memory copy of the old contents of
the portion of the memory that this transaction
is going to modify. And that's what is
called the in-memory undo record of LRVM. In
the body of the transaction the program is doing
normal program writes and they are going into
the memory. No problem with that because LRVM
has the undo record already stashed away. So
all of these are writes to normal memory and
there is no interaction with LRVM during
this portion of the transaction code. Then
the application reaches the end transaction, makes
the end transaction call to LRVM. At that
point, LRVM is going to write a redo record onto the disk when the
transaction commits, because end transaction is synonymous
with commiting, so far as LRVM is concerned.
And therefore, at this point, the changes that have been made to virtual memory
are written out as a redo log record and forced to the disk by LRVM. We know
disk I/O is slow and the more you do it, the slower will be the subsystem
that is using these LRVM primitives, and that's
why LRVM provides the no-flush option in transaction
call, which allows an applicaiton to tell LRVM write
it out to the disc but don't stop me
from progressing further in my computation. In other words,
the applicaiton is hoping that there won't be any failures
that will result in all the changes that it
recorded in memory not being forced to the disc. So
the LRVM is going to write out the redo log
as the background activity and the hope is that there
won't be any system crash during the time that it takes for it to do. And this
is what we called as the window of vulnerability
when we talked about LRVM. So what the no
flash option does is to increase the vulnerability
of the system to power failures in favor of
performance. And that's a calculated risk an application developer
is taking if they specify no-flush optimization in the
end transaction. So, on the other hand, if
you are conservative then what you would do is
you let the end transaction have the normal transaction
semantic ,which to say that adding transaction force the
write of the log into the disc to ensure
that the log segment has been commmited to the
disc. And only then allow the application to proceed
further. And at this point, at the commit point,
the other thing that LRVM would do is, in
addition to forcing the log record to the disc,
it will also get rid of the undo record
because the undo record is no longer needed for
this transaction since the transaction was successfully committed. And we know
as a background activity what LRVM does is to update the
original data segments with the changes that have been recorded in the redo logs
because, as you recall, the data segment contains
a persistent data which are being brought into memory
and modified during this transaction. And those changes had
to be eventually persistent. Right now, they're sitting in
the redo log records and what the log truncation
part of the elarvian library does is to read
the redo log records and apply them to the
data segment and get rid of the redo logs.
So this is the log truncation or clean-up
of the disk space that is done periodically by
LRVM. Because in the absence of crashes you have
to make sure that you clean up the disk
every once in a while. So the upshot
of LRVM implementation is there are three copies of
the VM space, done by LRVM to manage persistence
for recoverable objects. Of course, it optimizes log force
by dealing them at transaction endpoint. But
in implementing LRVM one of the biggest sources
of vulnerability is power failure. Because if
you, in fact, use at optimization to defer
writing out the log record to the permanent storage, then all the work that
you did in this transaction may actually be wasted if in fact there is a power
failure before the log force happens. Now
what does providing a battery-backed DRAM give you?